à jean de la fontaine les cinq classes
seront bientôt complètement occupé en
septembre 2018 les élans courtois
accueilleront démord pas bien un projet
mené par les deux communes
première école intercommunale de saint
quentin en yvelines avec deux écoles qui
perdent des effectifs et on n'aura pas
de constructions nouvelles dans les
années qui viennent et donc au lieu
d'avoir justement l'école de la vie du
parc avec seulement deux classes depuis
la rentrée 2016 avec des interrogations
des parents qui sont légitimes sur
l'avenir de cette école la maternelle de
la ville parc accueille actuellement 48
élèves s'échangeront d'établissement il
ne parcourront qu'une dizaine de mètres
le problème sur la fontaine c'est qu'on
a deux classes le vide
[Musique]
ville parc c'est pareil donc c'est ça
qui entraîne que bon voilà on va pas il
faut exploitent ces deux équipements
sont sous-exploitées c'est là c'est
donc le constat est là la solution vu la
proximité des deux communes aussi bien
en nombre de maîtres queux en termes de
méthode ou en termes de culture
ça semble évident de fictivement de
rapprocher ces deux écoles pour mort pas
ce changement s'inscrit dans le projet
génération la ville parc accueillera en
septembre 2019 les tout-petits de la
crèche des au boulot destiné à être
réaménagé pour devenir une résidence
pour seniors